hello everyone i hope you are doing well
uh i'm alana welcome to my channel where
today i wanted to talk about something
that is a little bit more serious um
that i feel like
isn't getting a lot of coverage or isn't
likely to get a lot of coverage
despite the importance of it because it
is very insular to the uh games industry
um but a lot of people who work in the
games industry have been affected by
this so
the story on gamesindustry.biz follows a
number of tweets last year about the
same situation the headline is of course
igda mishandled complaints of harassment
and conduct violations
and a number of developers have come
forward and criticized the industry for
ignoring the harassment allegations and
failing to investigate complaints and i
want to say that um
you know before i decided to jump in on
this and and to also call out the
international game developers
association who is the igda
i have seen all of the documents of
evidence that was submitted to the igda
and they are extensive hundreds of pages
of documentation
regarding this particular case
um and and so many people um it is
unfortunately difficult to talk about uh
to any great length because when i
reached out to a number of people and
was like hey i want to cover this i want
to talk about
what happened here um of course a lot of
people want to maintain their privacy so
um
it is difficult to navigate but still
something that we need to talk about
before we go any further into this video
and i even explain the situation to
majority of you who maybe don't know
what this is about i wanted to make the
note that i think it is extremely
important that the igda even reaches out
and apologizes to the people who are
wronged by this situation they wrote
some tweets and they've even been
retweeting some of the victims which is
very odd but at no point have they
actually apologized to these people and
i just wanted to get the jump on saying
that very very early if anyone at the
igda is watching if anyone who is a game
developer is watching i know a lot of
devs do follow my channel before we even
get into the bulk of the story hello
igda please reach out and actually
apologize to the people who are wronged
back to the video let's go over the
article here this is written by marie
d'alessandri i really hope that i'm
pronouncing my name correctly it says
in the summer of 2020 the games industry
saw a cluster of sexual harassment and
abusive workplace scandals at a host of
high-profile companies ubisoft and
insomniac among them as the situation
unfolded the international game
developers association publicly
criticized the industry for ignoring
harassment allegations and encouraged
victims to reach out for the igda for
support which is the problem um they did
yeah according to games industry dot biz
investigation which i personally uh am
willing to back up because i did my own
investigation uh despite the igda's
pledge to support victims it mishandled
multiple formal complaints against its
own women in game special interest group
chair and failed to follow on its own
policies on how to properly handle such
complaints on more than one occasion um
so for context
the complaints of harassment and abuse
were against
someone who is on their women in games
special interest group chair
um
and i think that's part of what makes
this situation so complicated is that
the
complicated is not the right word it's
not complicated this is very clear cut
there's so so so much evidence but
i think it's probably that it is
publicly difficult for the igda to
approach because the person who was
doing
uh engaging in abuse or harassment is a
woman um quite a well-known woman in the
game development scene and i think that
that probably
meant that they just didn't know
how to handle it unfortunately um which
i don't think is an excuse uh they have
a full um policy for responding to
harassment complaints which is
you can find all the details there if
you care to dig into that and from
everything that i've seen it's very
clear that they did not um
actually
kind of
abide to their own policies so the
guidelines describe a zero tolerance
policy towards acts of harassment which
the igda has already committed to as far
back as 2017 saying we encourage game
developers around the world to join the
igda in adopting a zero-tolerance policy
towards harassment and violence and
committing to a swift and fair response
in release and resolution to any
complaints in protecting the safety of
anyone who has been at the victim of
harassment and in supporting a diverse
and inclusive workplace and community
last year igda women in game special
interest group chair and igda foundation
next-gen leaders alumna jennifer show
stepped down from her position at the
igda of her own accord of following
accusations of manipulation harassment
and emotional abuse when the allegations
against sherl first emerged publicly the
igda said it had previously conducted an
investigation into the claims and
concluded there wasn't compelling
evidence of wrongdoing so it had decided
to maintain shell
in her position so obviously games
industry doctors looked into it again so
did i um there is so much evidence of
wrongdoing there is so much evidence of
wrongdoing um
i don't want to make this video about
jennifer shell at all because she's no
longer at the igda and she has stepped
down and
um i don't know that making this video
about jennifer schull is helpful to
really any of the victims or anybody
involved um
but
a lot of the stuff and the thing that i
think is the most concerning is that
she was taking credit for a lot of
people's work um so there are a lot of
people who still haven't been
appropriately credited uh like saying
that she worked at nasa um
on a program when she absolutely did not
and even her involvement of that was
because of someone else and not herself
um i don't want to get into the details
again because i'm not trying to
spotlight jennifer schull in this
situation but
not only were there people who were
effectively uh bullied out of the
industry because of uh conversations
suggesting that they had done things
they hadn't and very intentionally
manipulative tactics
i'm named in um one of the documents um
in that jennifer scholl was saying stuff
about me and uh i'm i don't care about
that at all but it can have a lot of
impact when somebody inside of an
industry is creating a negative uh
whisper network especially when there's
somebody who's seen as being respected
and not on the board of the igda which i
would say most people watching this
video probably aren't familiar with but
the whole game dev scene knows the igda
so when it comes from someone who's in
that kind of position it is a position
of power they have a lot of
uh impact they can control people's
careers they can they can prevent other
people from getting jobs they can really
really negatively impact people and the
evidence is so compelling so
the igda clearly made a mistake here i
still think the igda is an important
organization that has helped people more
than hurt people
but as it stands right now i'm not
seeing any accountability i'm seeing
this one post which i'm very glad that
uh gamesindustry.biz covered but
otherwise the igda
needs to continue to serve the industry
we do not want them gone uh the igda is
is so helpful to a lot of um
just just starting out game devs
such a valuable organization to the
industry
that they need to make sure and we need
to make sure that they are doing their
best and making sure what they
said was not compelling evidence of
wrongdoing never happens within that
organization again
and right now this story is largely
being ignored and i feel like that is
unacceptable
so it goes on to say games industry.biz
looked into the situation and unveiled a
concerning patent at the igda showing a
failure to follow through with internal
investigation system the organization
itself put in place to handle issues
such as harassment and violations of its
code of ethics after hearing complaints
about cheryl in 2018 jen mclean who is
executive director of both igda and igda
foundation until april 2019 encouraged a
group of complainants to file a formal
complaint which it did in early 2019. a
collective of 11 complainants put
together a 16-page document alleging
targeted bullying and toxic behavior and
sent it to the igda foundation the
complaint a copy of which has been
shared with games industry.biz documents
a history of deception bullying
defamation and abuse again i've seen
this and i agree showing breaches of the
igda foundation's code of conduct that
shell was meant to follow as a member of
the next gen leader program it's worth
mentioning that the program is intended
to support mid-career games industry
professionals as they transition to
leadership roles which again is also a
very important thing because the games
industry is full of people who just get
promoted because they've been there for
a long time and not because they're good
leaders it's a real problem uh as
indicated on the igdaf's website with a
focus on diversity and inclusivity and
it's unfortunate that in this situation
it seems that the people who were
targeted uh were largely women so even
if a woman is the perpetrator she was
still um very much hurting and defaming
other women um and negatively affecting
their careers though it was not only
limited to women so you know if you're
still focused on diversity and
inclusivity i don't think it's inclusive
to
ignore harassment from a woman that is
still at the expense of other women not
that it would be okay to ignore
harassment at the expense of men either
i'm not saying that i think men should
be harassed that's certainly not the
case
but it clearly does not focus on
diversity and inclusivity perhaps just
the appearance of it article goes on to
say the igda foundation's code of
conduct explicitly states that
unacceptable behavior includes
intimidating harassing abusive
discriminatory derogatory or demeaning
conduct the complaint received in 2019
depicts unprofessional conduct from
cheryl that can be qualified as
intimidating and demeaning including
taking credit for the work of others
again
this is the part of this that i think is
a huge and and really devastating
problem that i've spoken to so many
people involved about um
not everybody i don't have contact with
everybody uh who this has happened to
but the ones that i have um
literally like years and years of work
that that um this person took credit for
and then ran with and built a career on
top of and that stuff still hasn't been
publicly corrected and i did ask a
number of people
if they would like
um me to say something to try to
publicly correct their resumes
effectively but it seemed to most people
that as long as the whisper network
exists and people know
that um this is the case
it doesn't need to be super public like
it can be fixed internally within the
games industry and i hope that that's
true um because i guess people are
scared about you know having a public
spotlight on them regarding that kind of
thing which i think is totally fair it's
all very scary goes on to say the
complaint also shows a group of games
industry professionals some of them
veterans in their field clearly
uncomfortable working alongside sherl
and with her being a part of the next
gen leader program and asking the igda
foundation to do something about it but
the complaint was dismissed by the
organization which said there wasn't
enough evidence part of this um was that
they were told there wasn't enough
evidence so they went and got more and
there's so much
there's so much evidence i it's so
shocking
i respect that if somebody comes forward
about anything that you should be like
okay we need to actually do our due
diligence diligence look into this and i
do think that that's important that as
an organization that they should put the
work into to vet these kinds of things
there's so much evidence it's
overwhelming how much there is my god it
says at the time confidentiality was
even breached as the content of the
complaint was discussed within the igdaf
and we were told someone who knew and
supported shell reached out to one of
the complainants about the document the
content of which was supposed to be
confidential so they were supposed to be
submitting this thing confidentially but
it was clearly discussed internally and
then kind of spread which is also
unfortunate the igda foundation later
apologized to the complainant for
breaching confidentiality which cool
thanks
so mclean stepped down from her position
as executive director with the igda
nigda foundation before the sheryl
investigation was concluded but
encouraged the group to officially file
their complaint at the igda as well
in 2020 a collective of 14 victims and
six allies lodged a formal complaint
against jennifer shell with the igda
which was then headed by executive
director renee gridens renee gittin
sorry the 34-page document details the
multiple accounts of personal abuse and
professional breaches carried out by
jennifer shaw between the period of 2017
and 2020 and the igda policy for
responding to harassment complaints
states that the organization will
investigate incidents committed by or to
an employee staff member board member
igda chapter
sig leader volunteer or general member
of the igda or if the incident took
place at an igda affiliated event
gathering or workshop online or in
person and both of those things happened
um pretty clearly both of those things
happened so the article then breaks down
the igda policy at length i'll leave a
link in the description if you want to
read this thoroughly but i'm trying not
to lose you here because there is a lot
of information
there is the follow-up here that was the
total there is another follow-up here
about um yeah the igd are asking for
more elements to support the case which
they did in december
of 2020 sorry and it added 78 pages
again i have read those across both of
the formerly submitted complaints
the people who submitted them alleged
that jennifer shell had breached the
igda code of ethics by appropriating and
claiming the work of her peers as her
own she totally did and provided
evidence of such claims it also accused
shell of grooming emotional
emotional manipulation harassing and
ostracizing other industry members
particularly other women and physically
assaulting one of the complainants as
well
and this important came out uh because
of this in 2020 upon learning that shell
had been nominated for a game dev hero
award
uh 10 women from across the games
industry filed an objection with the
organizers following a conversation with
the complainants the organizers removed
her from consideration for the award
this information was confirmed by a game
dev heroes spokesperson who also
confirmed that the igda didn't contact
them to confirm or inquire about the
situation he did also get inside of the
game awards inaugural future class um
but was removed
as a reaction to the allegations coming
forward and there was also a note of the
fact that the igda added that sherl had
come under investigation for
inappropriate workplace behavior had a
previous employer but left before the
investigation was concluded
so yeah um obviously this is extremely
wordy
and
the general synopsis uh is that the igda
did not take the situation seriously
despite their own harassment policies
and what they preach essentially
again not trying to shut down the igda i
think what they do is important but i do
think that they need to be held
accountable to make sure that they're
doing their job correctly there are um
this is stuff that i actually didn't
know about in this article uh a number
of other sources who came forward with
complaints about the igda
talking about there being a gap in
communication and the system just being
very broken
and uh basically saying it's not like
they don't care
there's just definitely a thing of
keeping a very positive outlook even in
how they were their emails everything is
very positive there's nothing negative
so when you bring up things that are
negative they're always addressed in a
positive way sickeningly positive so
that is an issue that's true sometimes
you need to be negative to deal with
negative things they added that the igda
isn't giving game developers the
association they deserve as
communication attempts are weak and the
organization isn't listening to the
complaints sent its way which is
probably very difficult i would think in
reality the igda should be hiring
somebody who is an expert and knows how
to deal with this kind of stuff
and they did actually respond
apologizing for the lack of appropriate
support and recognizing the importance
of upholding policies and standards
they said the igda maintains follow-up
correspondence with complainants and
communicates conclusions of
investigations to parties directly
involved in reported violations however
in one of our recent ethics
investigations we reviewed materials
submitted to us and conducted an
interview with the accused before
concluding there was insufficient
evidence of wrongdoing the approach
failed to adhere to the igda policy for
responding to harassment complaints
established in april of 2018 as we
relied on written statements and did not
conduct individual interviews of the
name witnesses and materials which is
also wild they didn't reach out to the
victims and ask them for their input
they reached out to the harasser and ask
them for input
what
again the point is that they apologize
for this though they are apologizing
they say we apologize for not providing
proper support and communication to
everybody with serious concerns it is
one of our top priorities that all of
our members feel their concerns will be
treated appropriately so they have now
updated
their
policy for responding to harassment
complaints um and created a more
comprehensive igta ethics violation and
harassment investigation process and i
just
really really really hope that they are
held accountable and that this happens
there is also a report by uh luke
plunkett on kotaku and then we have the
speech from anna branburque who said
i don't know how to pronounce that
after almost four years of working on
this i can't believe we finally we can
finally talk openly about it jennifer
charlie manipulated stole other people's
work and left a trail of destruction in
every country she fled to because she
did uh travel a lot then the igda
continuously chose to protect her and
anna said the igda is in action after
our repeated and detailed statements of
complaint allowed jennifer to continue
causing harm to more people in various
communities and countries around the
world i held them partly responsible for
the harm that she continued to cause
since 2018. i've spoken to so many
victims who share eerily similar stories
detailing our patterns of abuse and
deception so have i personally um spoken
to a number of people who had very
similar experiences
many are still dealing with the
aftermath of the damage she caused not
just emotional but also physical to this
day
several also had their careers severely
impacted while some things would have
been understandably tricky for the igda
to action eg statements about personal
experiences they shouldn't have been
simply dismissed but how could they
ignore things that were so blatant e.g
stealing other people's work with so
much evidence provided and that is the
really confusing part and how did
jennifer have the audacity to claim such
absurdishly big things like having made
games with nasa as her own work and
winning awards for it while the people
who actually did the work on various
teams were harassed and silenced to the
point of long-term trauma
i still can't believe the igda chose to
do nothing i can't believe that despite
statements from so many people and
countless pages of clear evidence they
still chose to stand by her jennifer
used her role at the igda as a shield to
shirk accountability and pursu and
protect herself from critique but mostly
i can't believe they still haven't
contacted any of us
since the we decided to do nothing email
and that we had to find their admission
of fault as well as their apology to us
at the bottom of an article having only
sent it to an investigative journalist
instead igda and igdaf have done so much
incredible work through the years i for
one wouldn't even be in the games
industry today if it weren't for the
next gen leaders program but being
grateful for the good they've done
doesn't mean we can't hold them
accountable when they fail us and i
think this is a really important tweet i
think there are also cases to be made um
where a lot of people involved feel like
jennifer shell did do a lot of really
good advocacy work so they think that
she even while she was
uh
even while she was being abusive to a
number of people was on the outside
being very helpful and i had a really
similar experience um with a woman in
the games industry as well who i was
like publicly
she's so helpful and does such good work
but to me she's awful and so i was
always just like i will just let her
do the good stuff publicly and just
ignore her otherwise it's a completely
separate woman thankfully only one of
them everyone else is pretty great but
i've always been like i will support you
continue to do what you do but wow were
you an [ __ ] to me and it could be a
really complicated thing for people to
wrap their heads around and figure out
how to tackle it's like but if
what you do is generally good and what
you just do to me is kind of abusive
then i will take the generally good
and just ignore like the reputational
damage stuff
that you're doing it's very complicated
and i think this is an important note
here too from anna who says several
people over the past years have asked me
what my desired outcome is with all of
this ideally i want public
acknowledgement of harm caused a
correction of accreditation for stolen
work and a proper apology to her victims
from igda2 but mostly from jennifer
schull who still has not properly
apologized to victims um i believe she
just kind of left twitter when it
happened and
yeah i have spoken to a number of people
involved again about the public
acknowledgement of of their
um
the work that they did that she took
credit for but yeah unfortunately a lot
of people ended up being like i don't
know that i'm comfortable with this
being broadcast in this way so i really
hope that this can be corrected um in a
more kind of internal to the games
industry way because it is really
important it can make or break your
career when somebody steals credit for
the work that you did that's certainly
happened to me in my career just not
quite to the extent that it happened
with jennifer shell to a lot of people
it can be really frustrating to deal
with and definitely damaging
um and can you know make you want to
leave an industry so
that is unfortunately complicated but i
hope that any of the game devs who watch
this because i know there are a number
of people in dev who are subscribed to
my youtube channel that you are aware um
of this situation and that you know that
if there are things that you saw
jennifer shall get credit for if you
know of her that you make the effort in
your brain to go oh that was probably
other people on the team or other people
may deserve credit for this um because
there were things where people would say
oh like is that jenny's game even though
it was a game that she had barely worked
on and a bunch of other people made it
which is a really unfortunate thing um
that got obviously very out of hand so
yeah this is not an easy thing to talk
about by any means but i think the point
is that i want to talk about it i want
to make sure people know about it we're
not trying to get the igda shut down um
and
the the takeaway should be that
hopefully this can lead to something
positive that they do take these kind of
complaints more seriously in the future
that we do consider that um even people
who would be minorities in positions of
power can be capable of abuse and the
taking credit for other people's work
makes you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
there are a lot of really really really
talented people who had that taken away
from them um who hopefully as a result
of you know this being spoken about and
this coming out that can be fixed there
can be a change there i am aware that
most of my audience will be unfamiliar
with any of this and what i'm talking
about but i mean maybe that's part of
the point is that now you know the igda
is the international game developers
association they did not adhere to their
own harassment policies they effectively
supported somebody who had over 100
pages of documentation regarding
allegations of abuse and harassment
all of which is extremely compelling and
thorough and that the organizations that
are there to support people in game
development really need to do a better
job of supporting people in game
development and hopefully this is a
turning point for that
i will leave link to the article below
to everybody who is involved in this i
hope you are okay i'm so sorry that this
happened it sucks and i always feel like
we we need to just speak up when we see
this stuff happening because the truth
is there's probably a lot of people who
are affected by this situation who
thought it was just happening to them or
were like gaslight who felt like it was
their fault when really it wasn't it
happened to a lot of people on a global
scale and everybody was um very shy
about speaking up and of course it's
hard to speak up it's terrifying i i at
least hope it's comforting that um none
of these people were alone that is it
for me today everybody i will see you
guys next time bye